my partner shuts down every time I try
to talk to them about what we need to
work on so I end up having to reassure
them instead of us working together to
make a change how do I make sure we both
get heard what I hear from that is your
partner when you bring up something you
want to work on with them they take it
as damaging to their ego that I'm doing
something wrong that you're not happy
with me the key to that is to show that
you're coming just from the point of
view of I love you so much I care about
you so much I always want both of us to
be able to bring to each other the
things that we think can take our
relationship to the next level or
improve us